[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
number
157 which I don't know it feels Prime
all right so let's uh we'll just in our
head we'll check all of the possible
factors and see if any of them uh go in
and
um I think it probably is that's my
guess
Saturday I feel like I'm feeling
unprepared today uh we're gonna talk
about antibodies we're going to talk
about the Department of Defense the
problem with the field the journal
Nature the American
um
what exactly are they called the sorry
there's something about yeah the
American Academy of Pediatrics and
um some other fish I like actually fishy
fish fishy fish yeah that's all the rest
of it was fish talk because humans being
fictional but yeah this is this is what
more like what people think of when you
say fish to them this is it people will
be somewhat uh surprised and maybe
disappointed to discover that this is
how when we were teaching and the entire
room was full of people who knew that
people and other tetrapods are in fact
just as entitled to be called fish as
any of the things that you might find at
a fish market
um that we used fishy fish to designate
those things that look the way the Mind
thinks a fish ought to look and fish
more generally could refer to any of
those tetrapods yes so this week on Dark
Horse fish fish as usual as usual yes
it's a it's a it's a distinction that
you can use to annoy almost any of your
friends yes I'll fish the permanent
defense
a nature in the field as fish will be
actually you know you can understand
their behavior often disappointing in
and of itself much better if you think
of them as fish right in fact they are
almost all of the all of the people who
do disappointing things oh yes except
that we're all in it together we are all
in it together this is in fact
part of the problem here isn't it guys
we're all in it together and uh
we need to remember that we need to act
like it's true it gets really really
hard when some people are insistent that
it's not true and all that has to happen
is you need to get rid of like you know
half the population will be fine right
now that yeah there's a lot of that
style thinking and it keeps re-emerging
but it really does yeah yeah so uh I
guess we'll just uh a brief PSA
don't [ __ ] it up it's our planet too
thanks
um
yeah exactly by by fish who have seen
the writing on the wall which is
something that some fish do and see and
write and build walls exactly not all
fish do any of those things
anyone's still watching
it's not too three uh yeah it's not the
kind of fish we're gonna be talking
about today but um cave fish
have this toggle they can go between
eyeedness and eyelessness not within an
individual but in one generation uh
depending on whether or not they are in
fact in caves where there is no light
and therefore no need to uh need to have
eyes and the eyes are impacted liability
or you know the ceiling of the cave is
collapsed and now there's light and it
would be really useful to have eyes
after all you can get them back yeah
yeah yeah it's cool you can
biology be cool like that it
[Laughter]
botched the grammar in two different
ways but
um
okay
fine Logistics at the top of the hour
followed by our sponsors and then we'll
get into the meat of the discussion
today the fish which is debatably meat
never mind I'll get off the fish thing
now and we can just go straight to the
fishiness of all of the stuff that's
taken place yes
you can find and follow Dark Horse now
on uh Instagram LinkedIn Facebook
Twitter and
um and do that do that get announcements
about upcoming shows and such we follow
these live streams of course as always
and as usual as many times with live q
and A's you can ask your questions at
darkhorsesmissions.com
you can watch right now if you're
watching live if even if you're not
watching live you can watch on YouTube
or Odyssey Odyssey has the chat live on
it and there is an active chat going on
we can't see it but you can if you
choose to uh we always encourage you to
check out hunter-gatherer's Guide to the
21st century which is coming out in many
many new languages this year but the
original in English is the one that we
wrote and the translations are we
presume awesome but we can't assess
those as directly and of course every
week or nearly every week I've got
something new on Natural Selections and
this week I posted on some of the
surprising even even to us
surprisingly like critical roles uh that
Beavers play in uh in landscape
maintenance and development and you know
we can ask questions about what the
first Americans might have seen as they
emerged onto this
um maybe partially maybe completely
depending on when and who exactly ice
free landscape gap of North America and
how much less prone it was to fires and
droughts and and floods largely due to
the activity of beavers so one
correction you said the roles the
Beavers play they think of it as work
they they do I guess on the other hand
uh not having language like so many fish
they we can't ask them what they prefer
well but see beavers have this um this
mechanism for uh displaying displeasure
and it's really unambiguous and the
first time you hear it you think what
the hell has happened it was slapping at
the tail on the on the water surface so
we could try it out we could say this
around them and see whether it gets a
negative review
yes that presumes a lot about what they
can understand of course
uh we we have a store at
darkhorsestore.org with uh with great
products like one our producer our 18
year old son is wearing right now the
lie to a tyrant hoodie which he is not
probably going to display but if you
wanted to just uh scoot past he could uh
it's up it's up to him
okay he says no and of course we are
supported by our audience uh we
encourage you to subscribe
to the main Channel and the clips
Channel like share uh both our full
episode and and any clips that you think
are particularly share worthy or share
possible and you know having been
demonetized by YouTube over a year and a
half ago at this point uh we have we uh
are reliant on the support and uh the
support of those who can afford it among
our audience you can join one of our
patreons right now the question asking
period is open at mine for the Q a this
month the private q a that we do when
that q a is going to be is up in the air
at the moment because there's all sorts
of weird travel stuff happening last
minute but we will do it and those
questions are always a lot of fun for
those we are able to pay attention to
the chat because they're they're really
small Brett has conversations on his on
his patreon as well which are fantastic
I hear they are fantastic they are tight
little groups of people who we have a
basically a running conversation that we
make sure you can jump in at any point
and then
stick around as long as you like
actually open to to newcomers and new
ideas are you yep well you know I mean
the thing is it's
not entirely unlike what you and I
experienced and did at Evergreen where
we often in the same class would have
people who had taken three or four
programs from one or both of us
and along with people who were just
joining for the first time and you know
uh I'm sure a one-room schoolhouse has
its downsides but it also the idea of
mixing people at different levels of
understanding has spectacular benefits
including maybe most important among
them that the need to bring people along
who are new to the conversation keeps
the conversation from becoming some
jargon-filled right uh Niche where only
those who know the secret handshake can
get in and so an academic conference
it's not an academic conference it's not
it's quite the opposite so uh and I I
strongly recommend for anybody in any
context where they have something highly
technical or scientific to describe to
figure out how to get it into English
and um anyway an environment that forces
you to do that as a matter of courtesy
to people who uh show up in our smart
and interesting but don't know the
language yet it's a great training tool
nice that's awesome and also at both of
our patreons you can use access to the
Discord server where people are hanging
out a lot talking exchanging ideas
having book clubs sharing virtual drinks
making plans and to meet in real life as
well and again you can access that at
either of our patreons and of course we
have sponsors we carefully choose we
carefully vet and choose our sponsors
they are all products or services that
we actually and truly vouch for even if
as with the first sponsor this week it's
not some it's not a product that we have
specific need for but we make sure that
we know that it's an excellent product
so without further Ado our ads
our first sponsor this week is MD
hearing aid MD hearing aid makes high
quality simple and effective hearing
aids for a tiny fraction of what most
hearing aids cost
MD hearing aid was founded by an ENT
surgeon who made his mission to develop
a quality hearing aid that anyone could
afford most people who need a hearing
aid only require a few settings so he
removed several less often needed
components MD hearing aid has sold over
a million units and offers a 45-day
risk-free trial and money back guarantee
these hearing aids aim to fit so well
that no one will know you're wearing
them the rechargeable batteries last up
to 30 hours their volt plus model is
water resistant and up to three feet of
water and you don't need a prescription
to get one MD hearing aid is cut out the
middle man so you buy your hearing aid
directly from the source where
audiologists and licensed hearing
Specialists are available seven days a
week everyone can empathize with what it
feels like to be left out of a
conversation that others are enjoying
here's a testimonial from a friend of
ours who has substantial hearing loss
and who relies on hearing aids we asked
her to try the product and this is what
she said
with my particular type of hearing loss
a deep male voice in a noisy room is the
hardest situation for me to hear and
understand speech I wore the MD hearing
aid to have a conversation with a deep
voiced man in a room with a lot of white
noise the MD hearing aid passed the test
as my conversation partner's voice was
clear and understandable at a price
point of under a thousand dollars I was
amazed at how effective they are
empty hearing aid is bringing affordable
hearing to hundreds of thousands of
people people who might not otherwise be
able to afford high quality hearing aids
get Clinic level care for 90 less with
MD hearing aid go to
mdhearingaid.com and use promo code
Darkhorse to get their new buy one get
one deal a pair of hearing aids costs
just
149.99 and Dark Horse listeners also
receive a free extra charging case a
hundred dollar value so head to MD
hearing aid that's m d h e a r i n g a i
d.com and use promo code Darkhorse to
get their new buy one get one deal a
pair of hearing aids for only 149.99
our second sponsor this week is boink
that's moo plus oink Mike
is working hard to help save the family
farm and get its customers access to the
highest quality meat on Earth fully 97
of the chickens served in the U.S are
dipped in chlorine but Family Farms
don't tend to do that and the meat you
get from Mike has never had that done to
it founded by an 8th generation farmer
monk delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and wild caught Alaskan
salmon directly to your door Mike
Farmers Farm like our grandparents did
and as a result moink Mists
and as a result my meat tastes like it
should which is to say delicious I was
just salivating at the thought man
they're mean as good it really is good
Mark gives you total control over the
quality and source of your food you
choose the meat delivered in every box
from rib eyes to chicken breasts pork
chops to salmon fillets it's all
fantastic and you can cancel anytime
we love everything about this company
the fact that the meat is grass-fed and
finished on small farms the lovely
Publications that come along with it and
of course the meat itself pork beef lamb
chickens it's all completely delicious
consider starting the new year or
treating someone else in the new year to
some truly fabulous meat grown humanely
and with care and fantastic for you
Shark Tank host Kevin O'Leary called
moink's bacon the best bacon he's ever
tasted and I agree it's amazing
keep American family going by signing
signing up at moinkbox.com Dark Horse
right now and listeners of this show
will receive free filet mignons for a
year that's one year of the best filet
mignon you'll ever taste but for a
limited time spelled m-o-i-n-k
box.com slash Darkhorse that's
moinkbox.com Dark Horse are we
pronouncing it wrong Mike
how would you pronounce it
I think that is probably the better way
to pronounce it but it's harder to spell
granted I hadn't gotten that far but
all right let me always putting you know
cold water on your enthusiastic creative
Outburst because hard to spell because
hard to spell exactly exactly well I
never thought that this writing the
stuff down was a good idea in the first
place and that was somebody else you
came rather a little bit too late to
that point I couldn't stop that train it
was already uh invented for one thing
indeed um yep all right our final
sponsor this week is Vivo Barefoot who
makes shoes made for feet regular
listeners will be familiar with Vivo by
now but if you're not you are in for a
treat seriously try these shoes most
shoes are made for someone's idea of
what feet should be vivos however are
made by people with feet who know how to
use them
here at Darkhorse we love these shoes
they are Beyond comfortable the tactile
feedback from the surfaces you're
walking on is amazing they cause no pain
because there are no pressure points
forcing your feet into odd positions
they're fantastic our feet are the
product of millions of years of
evolution that's like three million
years of upright Evolution which is my
math is correct is like 26 billion hours
of upright evolution
all right you at least didn't spot a
flaw in the calculation I think the
chances you landed on the right number
Arlo I'm very well we are gonna hear
about it if I did also I'm not I don't
know 3 million
of upright Evolution I picked a
particular ancestor and we can over
dinner we will discuss whether I've got
the right ancestor to begin the question
of human foot evolution
yeah right okay
but I digress you do how often
um humans evolve to walk move and run
Barefoot modern shoes that are overly
cushioned and strangely shaped have
negatively impacted foot function and
are contributing to a Health crisis
people move less than they might in part
because their shoes make their feet hurt
enter Vivo Barefoot Vivo barefoot shoes
are designed wide to provide natural
stability thin to enable you to feel
more and flexible to help you build your
natural strength from the ground up foot
strength increases by 60 in a matter of
months just by walking around in them
the number of people wearing Vivo
Barefoot is growing once people start
wearing these shoes they don't seem to
stop people Barefoot has a great range
of Footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
and everyday wear they're a certified B
Corp that is pioneering regenerative
business principles and their Footwear
is produced using sustainably sourced
natural and recycled materials with the
aim to protect the natural world so you
can run wild on it
go to vivobarefoot.com Darkhorse to get
an exclusive offer of 20 off
additionally all new customers get a 100
day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do that's v i v
o b a r e f o o t.com slash Darkhorse
awesome
um 157 is prime
it is it felt Prime that often means
nothing exactly that is one of the ways
that our brains
uh like to trick us especially the
bigger the bigger the number uh the more
likely we are to assume it's Prime and
it's not I'm imagining a great Series in
which the superheroes superpower is
known what's prime just by looking at it
wouldn't that be cool no
all right I mean back to the drawing
board
a I feel like some people you're like
math savants have you know effectively
have this ability right and uh and you
know maybe some people who aren't even
savants who actually are you know have
you know it's it's not the one skill
they have but actually have a lot of
skills and they're just really good at
that thing yeah
um
yeah but I feel like and you know I'm
not I am not an expert on superhero
culture at all uh but I feel like in
general
there has to be a practical use
for the superpower are you kidding you
don't think that's practical so uh you
and I both remember from our childhood
yes the the Wonder Twins oh yeah the
Wonder Twins yes which were a a boy and
a girl a brother and sister wow I just
no it's actually would have been a boy
and a girl good I actually I actually
can't remember
what her what she did
but he she would turn she would turn
into something I think it was an animal
an animal and then they like Wonder Twin
powers activate and he turns into
something made of ice or water made of
any water
could be acceptable and um and it was
such a such a cheat and so awesome as
well yes it was a it was an interesting
experiment in constraints practical even
though
um unfounded in the land of like physics
as most superpowers are I guess right no
it's like I mean you know you get you
get to violate one Law Office like uh
your credit card you get to pick one
perk you know can be miles it can be uh
cash back or whatever but superpowers is
like credit cards he says that's I guess
we're done for the day that's that's
what we came here to tell you we've uh
We've accomplished it it's going to be
downhill from there if we keep going so
anyway it's been
lovely yes yeah yeah uh you were gonna
defend your choice of superpower as uh
being able to uh
without thinking say whether or not
instantly any number no matter how big
um
I get with the superpower right
I'm hoping that it will become suddenly
obvious to you where your error was and
how great a superpower I'm gonna explain
it to you yes exactly that would be most
appreciated because at the moment I'm
struggling to come up with a value
application
isn't there a practical application in
cryptography granted this is something
I've always been a little vague on but
um factoring numbers is the key to
Breaking hard encryption I think well
we'll find out also in the comments when
people write in and tell me that I don't
know what I'm talking about but I think
perhaps the emergent superpower of being
really awesome at breaking code might
include as one of the more fundamental
uh sort of you know fundamental
superpower ATS uh recognizing primes at
a glance I mean we've done online we
have teamed up on a real legitimate
superpower that would be of spectacular
value the code cracker look
all right you're envisioning this as a
white superhero then
I was not
do you want to talk about antibodies I I
suppose
oh well actually actually you know what
maybe maybe we should start by talking
about
no
no welcome back there advice it is all
right
um I was inspired
to uh basically here's the thing I said
something offhanded in response to Joe
Rogan a couple weeks back
was that a couple weeks boy it doesn't
feel like it but I think it must have
been a week and a half yeah a week and a
half something like that anyway he asked
me a question I've now forgotten what it
was about antibodies
um and I said to him I said look I think
the co the um concept of antibodies has
loomed way too large in the public
Conversation Over immunity in the
context of covid and my guess is that
the reason
we have focused on antibodies is because
the public knows what an antibody is yes
agree to kind of loosely but
um but the point is when you say
antibody
um
it immediately conjures something right
whereas you know if you talked about
almost any other concept if I say clonal
selection right which is a you know
fundamental Concept in Immunology almost
nobody knows what you're talking about
so
I do think that this is
it's almost a tell that suggests that
what we are faced with is propaganda
so I don't I haven't I haven't listened
to that part of the clip and I'm so I
may stop me if this just isn't making no
sense at all but but so your argument is
that maybe part of the reason that we're
talking about antibodies so much is
simply because
the the um the public already knows what
they are and so it's sort of ready to
receive this sort of talk but it feels
to me like it's also true and I haven't
gone back and reviewed this at all so I
may be wrong here but it's also true uh
that antibodies are easier to to find in
in the body like they're easier to test
for than say t cells and so you know we
have we have
clinical tests that find the thing
that's easy to measure and that people
already know about so I mean it feels
like it could be both and unless I'm
wrong but but no you're not just right
like right you're not wrong it's an easy
it's an easy assay it's an easy yeah PCR
and it's the it's the wrong thing to be
doing right uh for for a number of
reasons but uh those those two reasons
which have nothing to do with whether or
not they're the right thing make it the
easy and um publicly amenable thing to
be talking about yeah I get it right
um it's something that we can talk about
because we're more likely to have
information about it because it's easier
to come by that information it's less
arduous I don't think that's really
driving this
um at all in fact we can see even in
the recent testing that was used I think
it was for the eua for the childhood
so-called vaccines where they had
measured
antibodies and claimed that that implied
that these were very good at creating
immunity to Modern variants and the
point is there was a giant leap in there
right which is it's not clear first of
all antibodies aren't what people think
right this is you're peering into a
complex system and you were able to
identify something and that is resulting
you say oh there are a whole bunch of
antibodies and it doesn't inherently
mean anything in fact antibodies can be
negative they can make the disease more
capable of getting into your cells so
um anyway I do feel like it is
indicative of the propagandistic nature
of our discussion that we are being
presented with something that can then
you know emerge into the conversation
where people are then talking to each
other about antibodies because they know
a little something about antibodies
whereas if you were talking about
receptors on a T Cell they'd be
scratching their heads what's the
receptor what is a T Cell why would a
receptor be useful in this battle you
know so anyway there is something weird
about the focus on on antibodies
and so anyway off the cuff said to Joe
that I think it's about the uh the fact
that the public knows what they are
rather than the fact that that's where
the conversation should be centered and
uh then a friend of ours uh Jimmy Kim
pursued this question I did ask her and
she was at least somewhat uh inspired to
look into it because of my comment to
Joe
um but anyway what she came up with is
very interesting and I'll just sort of
loosely say what it is I would suggest
everybody check out hey Zach can you
show uh Jimmy sub stack post
um so I would suggest people uh check
out her sub stack she has done a bunch
of these deep Dives she's very good at
doing this in plain English so that it's
very accessible she's highly capable as
a biologist so the technical matter is
all right she's not cheating on the
technical stuff but she presents it in a
way you can understand why she reaches
the conclusion she does she presents
with the references so anyways it's
really good stuff yeah and for those
just listing her sub stack is called
let's be clear it's really quite
excellent it really is quite excellent
um so anyway what she
discusses in here is all of the little
threads of evidence that suggest that uh
at the very least antibodies are not the
um the end-all and be-all of immunity to
covid and she goes through some evidence
that I was frankly unaware of now that
I've seen her explore it yeah I would
have I should have wondered if the if
the evidence existed in this form but if
people who can't produce antibodies for
one of a number of reasons either
because they're on a drug that is
suppressing their production of
antibodies or they have a congenital
defect that causes them not to be
producing antibodies and as she
correctly points out the fact that these
people are not doomed by covid means
they are successfully fending it off
which implies a whole other system that
is not captured in the oh my God it
creates a great titer of antibodies
um so anyway those who are more deeply
knowledgeable about Immunology will spot
at least one of the other component of
that system which is that we basically
have two kinds of circulating cells that
manage this very specific kind of
immunity right that is an adaptive
immunity that learns to fend off a
pathogen right
we have B cells B cells have receptors
on them and they produce free-floating
antibodies and those two things have a
relationship so when a receptor is
triggered by an antigen then the release
of antibodies occurs in at least many
cases whereas a T cell produces no
free-floating antibodies it has
receptors it gets triggered and they
create lots of other phenomena they can
for example people will remember our
discussion from I think last week and
many other times where we discussed the
question of what happens when your own
cell is producing not only your own
antigens but is producing foreign
antigens well that cell gets destroyed
the body destroys it and it destroys it
using T cells these T cells identify
this compromised cell they in any
natural case that I know of
a cell that is producing foreign
antigens and self antigens is an
infected cell and so killing it is the
way to get rid of it right it's bad to
kill your own cells but it's better to
do that than leave them in place so
anyway you've got these two different
systems and so the fact that the B cell
antibody based immunity is not the sum
total of covet immunity clearly is
evidenced by I mean it is never right
for any
for any illness for any pathogen
response is it ever entirely b-cell well
there will be things that are primarily
B cell so for example what are the
conditions that uh predict
it's a good question
um this is off the top of my head having
studied this many many years ago and you
know as an undergraduate in a medical
school class but nonetheless it's been a
long time and uh the field has grown and
I've learned a lot during kova that I
didn't learn back then but uh but for
example if you had a bacterium
right you might there's some bacteria
that you might fend off by just gumming
them up with antibodies that would then
cause them to be consumed by macrophages
right that might be the go-to mechanism
and because the bacterium is not getting
into your cells T cells might be uh none
of the response or not primary so you
know I hesitate to say anything in
absolute terms in biology because as as
my advisor and and uh member of your
committee Dick Alexander would always
say is like you know that's the quickest
route to be wrong because biology you
know
you used to make this point about
insects that anything you think never
happens in animals check out insects
you'll find it's there somewhere yeah
um
well it's a it seems like one
Trend that for which there will be
exceptions will be that uh single acute
exposure to something uh might be your
body might launch a successful immune
response uh entirely or almost entirely
with B cells and eradicate it and if
you're not exposed to it again like it's
it's gone right now this is actually
covers one of the things so my purpose
today is to actually just get people
used to hearing about this because I
have a feeling where the conversation is
about to go is hey is this antibody
stuff really what we've been led to
believe or is it being used to Mesmerize
us when there's a larger conversation
that might say something very different
right and so
um one thing that is the case right
people have a I'm now understanding
people have a misunderstanding in their
mind about antibodies being the result
of either
uh natural immunity developed in
response to infection
uh or
um
um or vaccination acquired immunity from
a vaccination for instance and what this
misses is that in fact and
forgive me if you've heard this before
but there is a system that has a
rudimentary set of cells that are not
highly effective at attacking any
pathogen they haven't seen but have a
basic ability to attack anything that
isn't self right and so the point is it
is wrong if what you've got in your mind
is oh I need something to create
antibodies and I'm not going to have
that until I've been infected with the
pathogen or I've gotten a vaccine let's
say a classic vaccine that does this
well that's not really right what
happens if you get infected with a
pathogen that you have never seen before
is a process of evolution is triggered
inside your immune system and what
literally happens and I believe it is
the most interesting biological fact I
am aware of but what happens is
your cells be they be or T cells or both
literally evolve they evolve on the time
scale that pathogens evolve and they do
so what they do is they take that crude
ability to uh electromagnetically attach
right or to be triggered in the case of
a receptor they take that crude ability
and they refine it and the way they do
this is through something called clonal
selection where those that tiny subset
of your immune cells that is triggered
by some pathogen you've never seen right
it induces the cells that produce either
that antibody or has those receptors on
its surface
to diversify to produce daughter cells
that are not alike they are actually
programmed to be not alike and then that
fraction of the daughter cells that is
best triggered then produces its own
daughter cell so you get this rapid
pattern of evolution right it's a
confusing language but it's called
clinical selection
well
not I mean it if you know the daughter
cells are different uh it's
and you have in your head what most
people have in their head about what a
clone means ah it's confusing language
well it's actually a little bit like our
uh many earlier discussions about why
chromosomes are not the end-all and
be-all of sex determination even in
humans where sex is determined through
chromosomes right the point is you we
tend we'll notice the pattern that there
is a chromosomal pattern that men tend
to be X Y women tend to be xx and so
strongly so that we tend to want to
synonymize them but as you point out
um the real the the thing that really is
not a broken pattern is that there are
two are more ancient than genetic sex
determination right is the gamete size
which actually dictates what is male and
what's female so the shortcut of saying
oh it's the chromosomes gets you in
trouble and in the same way here the
idea that clone means identical right is
not right what's actually happening is
you've got
um an asexual process that has a random
number generator triggered in it in
order to get diversity it's a cheat to
bypass sex as a mechanism for producing
diversity right so it really is clonal
and it really is selection in fact
um
Peter meadowar was one of the Pioneers
here Peter medowar who I believe got the
Nobel Prize he's a British biologist got
the Nobel Prize for discovering the
basis of graft rejection right graft
rejection being the result of the fact
that if you take a organ from somebody
who has your blood type so there's no
big antigen incompatibility and you
transplant it into you well it still
isn't self right they've spelled all of
the proteins differently and so your
immune system will attack it right and
so getting a match
a molecular electromagnetic match for
you is important which is why it's so
hard to find a donor right somebody had
somebody has to die who has that match
before you get an organ that you're not
going to reject
but in any case Okay so you've got these
cells that are capable of uh evolving to
get better but what that means is that
you have the rudimentary cells the
library the crude library of you know
it's not the Super refined tool that
fits the thing just so it's the
adjustable crescent wrench that fits it
kinda right it's that kind of thing but
that isn't nothing in fact it's keeping
you alive right that thing which is
always surveilling for looking for
hostile pathogens to get the place to
start the process of evolving a good
response is ever present right and so
anyway the antibodies in that response
is always available it's just not high
quality and the thing that vaccines do
and now I'm talking about Good vaccines
in which nobody would argue that they're
anything other than vaccines
what those things do is they provide an
advanced warning
right they provide a description of the
of the the Hostile entity in advance so
that that process of learning the
molecular signal the electromagnetic
signal of those antigens can be done
when you're not sick right or minimally
sick in the case of a uh of a attenuated
virus vaccine right so you do that work
when you're not challenged by the thing
and then you run into things like oh I
already know how to beat that in fact
I'm going to beat it I've got a head
start my immune system has a head start
on you because I haven't seen you before
but I've seen something like you enough
that I'm ready right and so presumably
we are constantly being invaded by
viruses and other pathogens for which we
already have the formula and we never
get any symptoms because we beat them so
quickly right and so that's how it's
supposed to work but don't get the idea
that you don't have the immunity until
something either the infection or a
vaccine gives it to you that's just not
right well but I mean it is also true
that quite possibly some of why so many
people are so sick right now
you know oh the triple threat right it's
SARS cov2 and flu and RSV like well okay
but why are so many people so
susceptible this year right because we
just spent a long time in effective in
many places for many people to varying
degrees in social isolation wearing
masks you know basically you know
basically preventing ourselves from
being exposed at low level to things
that kept our immune systems in in the
process of sort of priming themselves so
I hear explanations like this they are
plausible I am not certain that they are
true they could well be I want to be a
little bit cautious about it it feels
related to me to the hygiene hypothesis
right the hygiene hypothesis which is
that we are keeping our homes we are we
are clearing our homes of all possible
you know bacteria and other pathogens
and children raised in such homes end up
with a higher level of allergies and
susceptibility to things like the common
cold
and so this the hygiene hypothesis does
not specify a mechanism but it feels
like it goes in exactly the same
direction so I I feel like the um the
burden of that that's not true the you
know the fact that we forced everyone to
socially isolate and wear masks and such
for years uh is not contributing to a
higher responsiveness to low level and
not so low-level viruses and other
pathogens now I think the burden of
proof of that is on the people who are
saying it's not so I I think there are
multiple things that maybe contributing
to the same pattern or at least our
viable hypotheses
um what you and I would call confounds
and what kids today and doctors call
confounders but anyway
um
so to put a couple of them on the a the
hydrogen hypothesis and the version of
it that would apply to this I think is
almost certain to be true uh during
development in other words the immune
system during development gets exposures
that are useful
um the question of whether or not adults
are getting sick with these things
because of a couple of years of
increased isolation certainly plausible
that there is a kind of
censusing of the pathogen environment in
which you're basically low level
vaccinating yourself and I've heard
doctors talk about this uh
Zach's pediatrician when he was a a baby
uh used to talk about his good
pediatrician he's a good pediatrician uh
I think his name may have been Peterson
but um in any case he uh he used to talk
about the fact that he didn't get sick
and he attributed to that he the doctor
didn't get sick even though he's coming
every day into a practice with a lot of
young sick kids right and what he
thought was going on right or wrong was
that he was being exposed to all you
know the kids are around snotting up his
office and
um and he's exposed to this stuff and
basically he's constantly up to date on
the library of what's out there right so
that's possible
other things that are possible is that
there's Evolution on the pathogen front
so we had a year with almost no flu
right right now maybe that's [ __ ]
maybe flu ended up disguised as covid
because the powers that be wanted to
count it that way but if we take the
lack of flu at face value I think it's
pretty clear why that would have
happened right we did something that
interrupted our normal ecology which
interrupted its ecology which is
suddenly the mechanism that it uses to
infect people it transmit broken because
it's not doesn't have access to
airplanes and you know indoor
restaurants and all the stuff that we
weren't doing and so I mean the obvious
prediction here of course is that in
places that that stopped the lockdowns
early that didn't have the social
isolation and close the schools and such
there won't be as much of a surge uh
right now in respiratory viruses
probably except that we are all
intermingling exactly and so you know I
do wonder if you if you take a pathogen
and you suddenly accidentally get wise
to blocking it by you know
doing some Draconian anti-social
distancing whatever it is and the
pathogen responds by turning up uh its
infectivity right because now it has to
jump gaps that it didn't have to jump
before if that's Suddenly at the point
you stop doing that could unleash a
surge right so I either way we created
an environment that might produce
conditions to encourage the evolution of
virulence right and at the same time
what did we do with these so-called
vaccines is we intervened in a complex
system that nobody knows enough about to
have done this and we did so in a way
that is now obviously dumb
um and in a way that is now we are
seeing evidence of weird consequences
that nobody predicted as far as I know
like igg4 the attenuation signal
suddenly rising in people who have been
multiply boosted
and the question is well that does a
couple of things that a causes a
suppression of immunity for the thing
for which these folks were or
potentially causes a suppression of
immunity in the case of the pathogen for
which they were boosted but it also
provides a uh a loophole in the immune
system that other pathogens can find
right it's not specific it's just it
causes an overall dampening well it's
like if you
um if you were running a military
operation which I'm not no thank you
um but if you were
a lot of good people but we know some of
those people the t's would be crossed
the eyes would be dotted that probably
that sucks
I was about not what I do
I was about to say uh before I was so
rudely interrupted I was about to say
that that would likely result in a great
decrease in Friendly Fire incidents okay
now what I was going to suggest is a
crude mechanism
I see
um a crude mechanism for preventing
Friendly Fire incidents
uh that uh presumably militaries use is
some sort of a hey I'm a friendly
transponder signal right which causes
something with the immune system now no
we're talking about an actual military
operation
um which neither of us are in charge of
but uh the point is if you if every tank
that is yours is putting out a signal
um that is you know heavily encrypted so
you can't the enemy can't put out that
signal itself then you could prevent uh
the targeting of those things but to the
extent that the enemy figures out how to
do this right to gets access to the code
and creates uh a transponder of its own
then the point is that's a loophole for
anything that they can put that
transponder on wait is this all like a
way to Circle back to code cracker our
new superhero you think no I don't have
a pun I'm working on it all the time but
I don't have one um
but anyway
point is that itt4 thing uh suggests
another mechanism that might be causing
us to see an uptick in these pathogens
so anyway that's three different things
that all point in the same direction and
make it harder for us to know uh if you
know which if any of these things or
possibly all of them are in play
um
okay
the other thing I wanted to talk about
was
that inside of this discussion about
antibodies we have now started
discussing different classes of
antibodies right we discussed IGG which
is the primary antibody uh thought to be
responsible at least in the case of SARS
cov2 and probably most viruses for
neutralizing these things but that is
what is induced by the early uh
inoculations
problem is and many people have now
raised this in different ways that this
is not ideally the kind of immunity that
you want to stop transmission of this
thing and it may be that at some level
the very design of this vaccination was
doomed from the start not to stop
transmission because it's in the wrong
place right your lymph can be full of
immune cells that are well alerted to
this pathogen but if your mucosa aren't
brimming over with antibodies that
identify the pathogen as soon as it
lands it can still get into your lungs
and so
um the way to think about this the way
to listen for it is that the antibodies
the class of antibodies that are
responsible for mucosal immunity is IGA
not IGG right so
um anyway and you may also have heard of
ige which is the one that paradoxically
seems to produce nothing but trouble
right it produces allergies right places
where you have an immune reaction to
stuff that is not a pathogen and
um that's not good you can in fact be
killed by your own immune response to
something that is not a pathogen like a
bee sting you'll be overwhelmed with
your own uh inflammation I wonder if it
might not have been in a in an earlier
era when we weren't able to travel with
such magical alacrity a uh a measure of
localness
you know if if
you are now being exposed to something
at 10 or 20 or 30 especially or 40. uh
you've never been exposed to before
maybe you have strayed into territory
where other things are going to be new
as well
hmm
interesting if it would if you would
take it as some kind of a proxy for
something
um interesting and thought anything like
that quite possible
yep uh but
yeah actually you know it sort of fits
with um
the discussion of the repulsion that
people the physical revulsion that is
sometimes felt about uh
foreign
stuff and Oh I thought you're gonna talk
about sick sickness oh well but that you
know let's put it this way um amongst
racists the belief that the other is not
only you know an economic threat or a
military threat but dirty disgusting
um so anyway who knows maybe there is
some some history that would explain
that and it's not uh just
um a trick a propagandistic trick yeah
interest and aside that I know you
you're still talking about IG
uh IG A and G here
um but one of the places where that
script gets very much flipped is in the
European arrival on the eastern coast of
North America where both Europeans and
Native Americans who they interacted
with perceived to the Native Americans
were very clean and the Europeans were
filthy and what the hell is wrong with
those people anyway the Europeans like
what what is wrong with those Europeans
how can they live like that right no it
it is true and then of course you know
um
at the point that the Europeans were
Landing in North America the game was
already in some sense over as a result
of the pathogen that had spread due to
early contact
um but you know clearly at some level
the Europeans were a pathological threat
that they didn't even presumably
understand yeah um right which is a
fascinating and very very tragic story
um back to immunoglobulin yeah back to
immuno immunoglobinal so uh
immunoglobulin is just a synonym for
antibody
um and it's what the IG stands
forgot right
um and you should know so this would be
better done with visuals although most
of our uh followers are just listening
anyway but
um the
the fact is these antibodies which you
have seen diagrammed a million times as
little y-shaped proteins where the tips
of the Y are the thing that sticks to
the antigen and then the tail is what
dictates what class IGA IDE IGG Etc
um the antibody is
um in but that thing has a close
evolutionary relationship to The
receptors
that sit on the surface of the B cells
so you can imagine if a B cell is
producing antibodies and those
antibodies find their Target and they
land that doesn't tell the B cell that
produced them anything special they're
not you know in contact so there have to
be receptors on the cell itself so that
the cell itself knows ah wait it's my
time it's like the bank guard who you
know spends an entire career sitting in
the bank where nothing happens and then
finally the robber shows up and it's
like Ah that's what I've been training
for right
um
so anyway The receptors on the you know
the T cells and the B cells have an
evolutionary relationship they're not
independent right these are two versions
of variation The evolutionary variations
on a theme
and The receptors and the antibodies
have a relationship and anyway they're
in lives the the story but that's
probably almost enough to cap this off
for today purpose being really just to
get people used to the conversation
since I think we're about to end up
talking about whether this campaign made
any sense in the first place you know
did this campaign meaning this kind of
uh treatment that was sold to us as a
vaccine yes what campaign the
vaccination campaign right creating IGG
immunity in your lymph and blood was
that ever did anybody think that that
was going to arrest the uh the progress
of this pathogen and if so by what
mechanism right you know an IGA response
in the mucosa might have blocked
transmission and there's a way to induce
that which is to produce the
pseudo-infection or the attenuated
infection in the mucosa where the mucosa
learns this
lesson instead of your lymph
um which is to say a different drug and
delivered differently right a nasal
vaccine of a traditional sort right and
I will say you know yes we will be
accused of conspiratorial thinking on
the other hand we've seen an awful lot
of collusion just to obscure the truth
so I don't know why we would uh draw a
line but
um there is an aspect in which there are
several different lines of evidence that
you know Pharma was very excited about
this platform and it's easy to see why
because once this platform is something
that people accept then r d is just
slashed like you know you get it takes
it takes no time at all which was one of
the selling points right like wow we are
so lucky that we got this so fast and
you know you you have a chance to
replace literally years right of r d and
then I mean I don't
I don't know how it is that they are
going to continue to justify clinical
trials being abbreviated uh like they
did but you know years into less than a
year is going to be quite a remarkable
cost savings well if they hadn't created
if the vaccines had been less
destructive than they turned out to be
or if they had been better at
controlling the story so that people
thought they were less destructive then
the answer is oh well this new platform
requires a whole new regulatory
structure because why would you spend
decades when the only thing you're
swapping out is a secant sequence right
so you can see their argument right you
can see them you know frothing at the
mouth frankly at the profits that
they're going to generate by trans
translating every vaccine into this new
platform and just you know shooting up
um
so it didn't work out that way and
hopefully people are awake enough or
enough people are awake enough that uh
you know
we'll say two brief things here one to
understand that as
fantastic as the potential of uh
inducing the production of uh proteins
using transfection with mRNA as much as
that has tremendous potential a
we don't know that it can be done
usefully and there's a basic safety
problem that is going to accompany every
single attempt and the basic safety
problem is
you're going to make the patient's cells
produce foreign antigen and that is
going to get them targeted by the
patient's immune system and unless you
have some really sophisticated way of
keeping that damage to some tissue where
you can afford it it's game over right
it's not it's not worth it and so anyway
to my way of thinking
um
that's where the conversation has to be
have you solved that problem if so tell
us how you've solved that problem and
we'll talk about whether or not what
you're saying makes any sense or if it
sounds like PR right but until you solve
that problem uh well you've just seen a
totally predictable disaster
um and we're not doing that again so
hopefully
um so anyway it's it's it's that
question written over all sorts of
vaccines that you know that they
basically want to change the process on
all right last thing is I wanted to
point out that uh in this discussion
about
um antibodies antibody immunity whether
antibody immunity is the
um the best kind of immunity that one
might uh want to induce with a vaccine
campaign there is also this interesting
paper that showed up in nature I only
briefly saw it before we went on today
but it's clearly relevant
um Zach do you want to put on that uh
that paper
uh yep
um so this is a report this is nature
um
and it talks about something which
people who've been watching Dark Horse
for some time will remember you and I
talked about earlier much earlier in the
pandemic the possibility that there
might be hybrid herd immunity that comes
from some people uh having received
their immunity through an inoculation
some people having that immunity through
exposure to the pathogen and that really
were the inoculations good at producing
a uh an immunity to Contracting the
disease that you could get there by a
combination of those two processes well
I haven't seen this paper yet but it
looks from just what I can see of the
abstract here that they at least looked
not just antibody response but also T
Cell response yep they did now scroll
down Zach if you would towards the end
of the abstract
[Music]
um
it says it says full vaccination was
crucial to provide hybrid immunity right
what you have to say if you're going to
publish in nature
um however when designing vaccine
strategies T-cell exhaustion after
multiple vaccinations should be
considered this is literally the first
time I've seen this paper yep
have you seen it enough to know on what
basis they are saying you know that that
looks encrypted that looks encoded to be
like okay we had to say these things and
we're going to be a little bit cryptic
here but what did they see what did they
made them conclude that you know T Cell
exhaustion after multiple vaccinations
should be considered which like given
the way abstracts are written now on
this topic that sounds like this is what
we found but we only you're able to say
maybe this right what they saw was a
substantial drop in T Cell reactivity
after multiple boosts by the vaccines
and the reason that I refig4 and T cell
are dropping uh igg4 is increasing which
is a continuation signal so yeah the the
right right I got a sine problem I gotta
keep track of the signs but igg4 is
increasing which is causing a drop in uh
responsiveness right and separately
T-cell responsiveness is dropping in
multiply inoculated people now
the implications of that are likely to
be
complex hard to parse but one thing at
the level of the discussion that we've
just had what this looks like is that
these particular inoculations whether
the people who designed and or produced
them knew what they were doing or not
seems to be dragging the uh battle
against SARS cov2 in those who have
subjected themselves at least to the
MRNA vaccination campaign dragging the
fight into the realm of B cells and
antibodies and away from T cells right
now
people who have studied viruses are
liable to be alarmed at that because
viral immunity over on the T Cell side
is likely to be superior and so this is
yet another variation on a theme didn't
see that exact result coming but we have
talked about things like
original antigenic sin original
antigenic sin means that once you've
given the immune system a potent message
about a particular pathogen the immune
system loses its objectivity it loses
its creativity and it becomes tracked
into making that first response that it
made and that is not a good thing right
you want the immune system to be dynamic
to be capable of Switching gears if it
needs to and tracking it into this one
response is not a good idea so that's
original antigenic sin there is antibody
dependent enhancement
in which a pathogen
utilizes the antibodies that it can
predict are going to land on its surface
as a mechanism for gaining access to
cells that it would not be otherwise
able to do and you know now we've got
attenuation signals right attenuation
signals uh are not in either of those
categories exactly but does seem like a
consequence of something analogous to
Original antigenic Sin
um and now we see T cells uh standing
down that's like you know is that a
consequence of an attenuation signal
what is it but in any case it's uh
it is so many different demonstrations
of what you and I said very simply
without
um any specificity at all right welcome
to complex systems you are intervening
in a
interaction between a pathogen and the
immune system that's one complex system
inside of a person that's another
complex system inside of a society in in
a pandemic okay but but that description
and we have said that multiple times by
that description so too is any vaccine
right so any any vaccine is going to
actually have those three layers of of
complexity
um that that is true about it and you
know what isn't included in the
rendering that you just gave is the
novelty up upon novelty upon novelty I
think there's at least three
um in the MRNA vaccines like you know
there are at least well yes so it's the
MRNA
um being used to effectively turn you
into a factory for the antigen yep it's
the introduction of the pseudo-uridine
into the MRNA so it doesn't Decay and
it's the lipid nanoparticles uh that are
coding the MRNA so that they aren't
found by the uh rnases yeah right
um in the intracellular space to to also
not let them Decay so all all three of
those things and I'm I'm sure there are
many more than that but those are the
three that come to mind like oh this is
this is so novel with no track record
right
um so I will just put an asterisk on
that last one on the lipid nanoparticles
are in and of themselves novel and who
knows what their consequence is but the
lack of a targeting mechanism so that
whatever they're doing is just happening
all over the body is a critical design
failure right um but
I agree with you it the nested complex
systems are always there it's the
intervening with something novel and
thinking that you know what's going to
happen oh no you don't right the best
thing you can do is you can work in a
way that is close is closely enough is
similar enough to something you've done
and seen the response and hopefully
tracked the consequences over the course
of decades following that gives you some
confidence that this works but even that
we've seen we've seen traditional
vaccines fail right you've seen them
introduced and we've seen safety signals
cause them to be removed from the market
and so the point is that's not foolproof
but at least it's something yeah right
and here what they did was an absolutely
at least triply novel intervention in a
nested series of complex systems where
you know it's just
obvious that they weren't going to be
able to predict the outcome and you know
it is much worse than it might have been
uh so far it's not as bad as it might
have been you know it's arbitrary in
terms of its level of terribleness but
it it you know it it was very unlikely
that with that level of novelty in that
level of complexity that their hopes
were going to be mirrored by the
consequence and we we've seen them uh
embarrassed or at least they should be
embarrassed at uh at what actually
happened
no I don't I don't see any evidence of
embarrassment honestly
um we are seeing more and more
suggestions uh that it is not as uh
those who are actually trying to help
Humanity would have hoped
but the evidence of embarrassment on
behalf of uh those who push these things
I don't see
I don't see it
um except that
actually the Department of Defense has
rescinded the vaccine mandate
for the military which is important
about time and I don't I don't have
anything in particular uh to to say
about this but you know but but just a
few a few a few details which is that
there seems to be and I hope to hear
about it if this has already changed or
I hope it will change there seems to be
nothing in
uh the I don't remember if it's a
declaration or whatever
um but in the in the new paperwork uh
that helps in any way those uh those
members of the military who were
relieved of Duty because they wouldn't
get vaccinated I think those those
people are still
um simply as screwed as they already
were by uh a uh unethical and
unreasonable mandate
um but for those people who were still
you know hoping for an exemption who had
a black mark on their record but Were
Somehow managing to still be in the
military uh all of those things are
supposed to now be be wiped clean which
you know it's it's it's about time and
uh we we talked I looked it up in um
Dark Horse number 112 or at 157 now so
this is uh closing in on a year ago uh
we discussed the widespread abandonment
of mandates in government and the
private sector
about a year ago early 2022
um but uh really three two large sectors
were keeping them and there's a third
that was that was keeping them partially
and one of the large sectors and the
third one are largely still in place so
you know this week the military drops
the mandates
terrific fantastic good job about time
but in the entertainment industry as
we've talked about before it still seems
to be de Reger to require mandates and
to be to be up to date you know whatever
that means uh to be up to date on all of
your shots even for children
okay and then the other place before
before we talk a little bit about this
is uh not all of higher ed and it was
never all of higher ed it was remarkably
the elite institutions and it just it's
such a perfect a perfect encapsulation
really of what has happened here that it
was the elite institutions that early on
started uh mandating vaccines for its
students for its young people and you
know who are most at risk from these
from these vaccines and at least risk
from the actual virus and it is them and
then you know later on some other
institutions sort of joined in the
Mandate game but most of them have
backed off and it's the elite
institutions who still have them for a
tremendous number of people and uh you
know isn't isn't that it right there the
the Nugget that it is the elite
institutions throughout this that have
revealed their failures to understand
basic logic and Science and to care
about Humanity both of those things
simultaneously so why are we still
listening
sorry
um tweeted something on this topic
earlier uh in the week and I think and
it leads to the
um piece of the puzzle I wanted to at
least
uh float today
for some reason we are living in an era
in which regulators
regulate only after the public has
become alarmed about something in other
words they're supposed to be regulating
so that the public doesn't have to
become alarmed because it's pretty well
protected but what's happening is the
level of harm has to be great enough
that the public can't ignore it and at
that point The Regulators will step in
and reluctantly regulate right the
vaccine mandate in the military is being
dropped late after public discussion
about the consequence of this for our
Readiness and it's including right here
on Dark Horse you did two fantastic
conversations with
service members and lo and one lawyer
yep yeah
um and so what is the meaning of that
you've got the Department of Defense
that is dragging its heels on dropping a
mandate that is crippling military
Readiness they should be the first
people to look out for military
Readiness they should be sensitive to
threats to military Readiness most of us
don't even understand and then in this
case it's it's the public discussion
that is driving them to do that likewise
we have newsrooms
right newsrooms there now you know the
Washington Post and the On The Wall
Street Journal are now reporting on the
possibility that the vaccine campaign
may be driving the evolution of variants
really I mean
so what we've got is The Newsroom is now
um embarrassed into reporting the news
that's what's going on right it's all of
these things are lagging and you're
pointing out that the elite institutions
which are the people you know every
faculty on in one of these Elite
universities should be brimming over
with people saying hey wait a minute
this is a complex system what are they
doing lipid nanoparticle how are they
going to prevent it from getting into
your heart every one of these
institutions should be full of people
who know enough to raise the right
questions to point to the right
historical instances that reveal the
danger of doing this kind of thing not
after Decades of the creation of
fictional departments and Fields uh such
that many people in The Faculty can't
tell up from down or two from two from
four right you know if if if they're if
they're going to engage in soft street
at the level of two play plus two might
not equal four then asking them to
consider the risks of complex systems
upon complex systems upon complex
systems especially when presented by
people with other credentials and the
right you know glassware and lamb coats
and such and who are using big words
that you know just you know follow the
scientism uh and think oh yes I will
because I know that in this house we
believe in science and you know it's
it's it's effectively loyalty how it's
all the way down and you know I am loyal
to science like no you're not you have
no idea what science is that's not what
science is you're being lied to oh and
it's over right
um it is upside down yeah right all of
these things and here's what I'm
concerned about though
if you think about the uh
military mandate being dropped and you
think about people discussing what just
happened 10 years from now
the discussion whether you understand
that the dod allowed military Readiness
to be crippled for years before finally
abandoning this policy right that's
going to depend on your ability to tell
2021 from 2023 right that's a minor
difference when you're looking at
history and it really erases the immense
period of time in which we were shouting
at them and saying what are you doing
military Readiness we're supposed to be
able to fight two simultaneous Wars on
two different fronts at once and you're
[ __ ] around with this stuff right
you're taking Pilots out of the air
you're grounding them what are you doing
you're supposed to be defending the
nation and so you know
I'm already dreading the arguments
five years from now when we're looking
back and it you know the ability to make
the argument about the jaw-dropping
insanity of what we went through comes
down to you know the last digit in a
four digit year right and you know
whether or not you know the Wall Street
Journal was aware of the variant issue
in you know 2023 or 2021 right that's a
huge difference how much happened in
those intervening years it was a ton and
they could have been talking about this
it wasn't hard we were talking about it
right they presumably have access to
YouTube they could have figured out that
this was a question so
I'm concerned that what's happening is
that we have successfully we the whole
community of dissidents has successfully
embarrassed the system into having to do
the bare minimum years late and that is
a tremendously important story but that
it will look like a footnote right oh
government's slow right so anyway I I
don't know how you prepare people that
that's the cover story they're building
but by doing all of these things late
they're
um covering their asses and leaving us
exposed to doing this all again yeah
they are
they are uh just show my screen very
briefly here Zach
Health and Human Services uh posts I am
over here oh it's unplugged at so many
levels not on my computer though due to
circumstances entirely under our control
exactly so Health and Human Services
publishes or posts the administration
for strategic preparedness and response
this week four days ago as we're live
streaming January 11th
renewal of determination that a public
health emergency exists
right so we've got another 90-day
extension on yep covet is a public
health emergency this is I think the
11th one
um
as a result of the continued
consequences of the coronavirus disease
2019 pandemic on this date and after
consultation with public health
officials as necessary I Xavier Becerra
apologies if I'm butchering his name
Secretary of Health and Human Services
pursuant to the authority invested in me
under Section 319
Etc do renew effective January 11 2023
the January 31st 2020 determination by
former secretary Alex amazar that he
previously renewed on and then they go
through all every 90 days
literally you could tell time by it it's
like clockwork every 90 days so we just
got renewed three days ago for another
90 days that this is a public health
emergency
which is its own Hall of Mirrors yeah
because they used these things as an
excuse on the other hand
um
I wouldn't even know how to call it well
so let's take a look briefly if if we
can if my computer will show
um at and I'll link to this Declarations
of a public health emergency what beyond
the 11
with regard to coronavirus to covid have
happened recently well we've got one
um oh also recurring every 90 90 days
the opioid crisis hmm I didn't know that
okay I'm not exactly sure what to think
of that but okay oh monkey pox November
2nd
okay maybe so then we've got
the hurricane in South Carolina on
September 30th the hurricane in Florida
on September 26th the hurricane of
Puerto Rico on September 20th
severe storms flooding landslides and
mudslides in Kentucky on August 2nd
wildfires and straight-line winds in New
Mexico so we've got
punctuated natural disasters that are
serious and they cause real
pointed moments in time when people were
at risk and there needed to be an
immediate response on the part of HHS
presumably and other agencies
and this whole list
is has those occasionally and then
mostly it's every 90 days yep sorry
scoby too
uh medical emergency opioid crisis
medical emergency and now maybe it's
going to start with monkey pox as well
so it's like it's like enduring us to
you're always in a state of emergency be
afraid be very very afraid and you know
make sure that you are on high alert at
all times and you know you don't need to
actually know anything about physiology
or about psychology to know that being
in a state of high alert at all times is
not good for you you make poorer
decisions you are more likely to be
confused and more able to be confused by
those who would like to confuse you so
this doesn't feel
accidental
like yeah it does it it doesn't no it
might be organic to this but it doesn't
it feels like we are being led into a
state of Perpetual I mean it's it's like
the the color coding of after after 9
11. right oh like you know if you're at
yellow or orange or red you know you may
be about to die like oh my god really I
can't live like this well yes but let us
help you yeah like this this is this is
no way to live
and this this that's been the case since
they started this 11 90 day intervals
ago
yeah 10 90 day intervals ago if this is
the 11th but it's like
so you know this ROM Emmanuel quote
never let a good crisis go to waste
right it's like that thing
um has run into the same
um
safetyism Obsession that is riddled
through everything else where
you know
I I really wish people would look at the
coven phenomenon
beyond the pandemic and they would look
at what it implies about
what our system is but the real question
is if we you know how many different
ways is what we are going through a
self-inflicted wound that's right what
you are pointing to
is here's a psychological self-inflicted
wound we've also got a lipid
nanoparticle pseudo-uridine enhanced
mRNA self-inflicted wound and then you
know what else we have we have a spike
protein encrusted nucleocapsid uh virus
SARS cov2 self-inflicted wound which is
the result of its own panic over
zoonotic viruses which we absolutely
have to enhance in the lab so that we'll
know what to do what kind of [ __ ]
argument is that right this is all
people you know basically jerking
funding mechanisms around by the
amygdala right it's just like you know
we better study this now or we're all
gonna really
that's what you think is that suddenly
the danger of a virus leaping out of a
bat in a cave is so great that we have
to enhance that virus and never mind all
of the prior cases in which viruses have
escaped from Labs where people had them
right I mean the story is just too dumb
but somehow people who have enough
precaution in them to prevent us from
overreacting are not allowed into the
conversation you're only allowed into
the conversation about pandemics if
you're panicked about the chance of one
leaping out of a cave at any moment and
what that means is this self-inflicted
wound was inevitable
yeah right the anybody who didn't think
that this was enough of a problem or
that you were going to make your problem
worse by enhancing viruses in the lab
wasn't welcome and
holy moly are we paying a huge price for
for this kind of um you know it's like
it's like some
insane field trip where everybody is
leaping out from bushes and you're
shouting in each other's ears all of a
sudden I you know it's everybody's
keeping each other on edge because that
allows them to you know
manipulate the system into spitting out
money or something that occurred to you
on field trips
no I was trying to think of what context
this would happen it didn't sound like a
board room to me but you know it doesn't
sound like any field trip I know no do
we have a better event that that's where
people leap out and try to startle each
other how about now well right here and
now yes because that that is that is the
point
what they're doing so um in that in that
milieu
uh what condition is the American
Academy of Pediatrics now suggesting the
remedy of drugs and surgery for what
what condition what child childhood
conditions the American Academy of
Pediatrics I'm going to read this is not
from the AAP the American Academy of
Pediatrics although I'll link to that
but CBS among everyone else reported on
this so I'm going to just read the first
three paragraphs alighting the condition
itself okay
children struggling with this condition
should be evaluated and treated early
and aggressively
including with medications for kids
12 and surgery for those as young as 13
according to new guidelines released
Monday
the long-standing practice of watchful
waiting or delaying treatment to see
whether children and teens outgrow or
overcome the condition on their own only
worsens the problem but affects more
than 14.4 million young people in the
U.S researchers say
left untreated the condition can lead to
lifelong health problems including high
blood pressure diabetes and depression
waiting doesn't work said co-author of
the first guidance on this condition in
15 years from the American Academy of
Pediatrics
waiting doesn't work can we talk to the
person who said waiting does work I just
think that both the argument should be
on the table
um
so
you've probably heard the story I
haven't you haven't no so do you so you
want to take a guess what condition I'm
reasonably confident I know what the
condition is and it's a killer yeah it's
a killer um the condition tell me if I'm
wrong is that some kids in this era
where frankly there are a lot of kids
with a lot of conditions some kids don't
have a condition and not having it wait
there's 14.4 million children in this
country without a condition that seems
high but that's terrifying well right
but well drugs exactly how they feel
exactly drugs and surgery because you
can I mean do you pick your condition
right you could decide what to the
operating theater with them exactly so
is that it lack of condition lack of
lack of any diagnosis
anything wrong with them exactly which
would make them feel like the odd man
out at school drugs is not too young or
a woman or no not drugs it's not too
young drugs is 12 is not two
and I am not on any at the moment that
was a brief moment of channeling George
W Bush who's the kids learning
um yeah 12 is not too young for drugs if
your child does not yet have a problem
right exactly drugs didn't work try
surgery
of course you got really far you weren't
anywhere close but you know the language
when you a lot when you take out the
name of the condition the idea you know
children struggling should be evaluated
and treated early and aggressively
including with medications for kids as
young as 12 in surgery for those as
young as 13. now the the ages aren't
quite the same but this sounds like the
same thing that they're doing with
regard to trans right this it sounds
like that and yet in this case
um it's not it's not trans it's obesity
it's being overweight it's the it's the
actual health problem of being
overweight but
what they're recommending is drugs and
surgery right for 12 and 13 year olds
and here's some other good quotations
from this from the CBS story
the co-director of the Center for
Pediatric obesity medicine at the
University of Minnesota said
obesity is not a lifestyle problem it is
not a lifestyle disease it predominantly
emerges from biological factors
because
until yesterday there were this many
overweight and obese kids in the world
and are still outside of the countries
that feed our kids complete garbage
no
this this is
cannot believe that a doctor whose job
this is is willing to go on the record
saying this
like
have you met doctors
sorry unfortunately a few like this and
the medical director for the AAP again
the American Academy Pediatrics
Institute for healthy childhood weight
and a co-author of the guideline said
this is no different this is not
different it's you know she was speaking
so that it's not quite grammatically
right but this is not different than you
have asthma and now we have an inhaler
for you
which
fascinating right like why are there so
many childhood allergies now why are so
many kids asthmatic and allergic to
things
because of what we're doing to them it's
because of what we're feeding them and
because we keep our houses two
completely clean of pathogens and yet
we're feeding them garbage and we've got
pollutants everywhere adjuvants and and
adjuvants
and the Obesity is the same thing once
you know once you're 30
and obese and you have been since you
were young
it's really tough like it's it's likely
that you're going to have a very very
hard time getting getting to a weight
that would have been considered healthy
for your height uh if if you had not
been obese your entire life but children
you you don't start with drugs and
surgery for children
you don't do that no it's it's insane
and it the pattern is there for every
one of these exploding pathologies right
you've got you know we have talked
extensively about the the orthodontia
version of this we there is obviously
something that we have changed about the
environment of children genes doesn't
make any sense as an explanation so it's
obviously something that we are doing
and the implication is if it's something
new that you're doing
is something you could stop doing right
right
um now in the uh in the case of obesity
how insane is it that we're going to
studiously pretend that the right thing
to do is drugs and surgery for children
who frankly maybe it's too late for them
but it's not too late for the children
who haven't been exposed to whatever it
is yet and we are not here's what we're
not going to do
we are not going to go after the ability
of Corporations to study the psychology
of children and to induce them to eat
more than they would otherwise eat and
eat different things than they would
otherwise eat as if that's not an
obvious suspect in the the question of
why childhood obesity is rising right we
are we are actually allowing
corporations to induce children into
self-harm right this is as bad as
allowing them to molest children right
you are we are harming children they
will their whole lives will be affected
by this and we are not looking at the
obvious culprits that we could obviously
do something about without touching the
kids right you could just simply say
look yeah I mean I've made this argument
not for just for food but I don't think
advertisers should have any right to
advertise to children they shouldn't
have the right to study children right
it is Our obligation to protect children
we don't have any control over the
ability of an Advertiser to get into a
kid's mind why are we letting them do
that right you wouldn't let a stranger
on the street who you know was trying to
con your kid is to talk to them so why
are we allowing them to do it through
screens it makes no sense
no it doesn't uh I cannot show my screen
is that right
okay that's fine uh the clinical
practice guideline for the evaluation
and treatment of Children and
adolescents with obesity is an
interesting document I have that's
that's the thing that came out this week
that everyone's reporting on
um I haven't read all of it but just
just the little blurb at the top of the
page
reads the first sentence 14 million U.S
children are affected by the serious and
complex chronic disease of obesity
how would you define disease yeah I
don't think I think that actually just
worked Zach I saw my screen Jump Around
um
I don't
metabolic disease right like in adults
having had uh you know a developmental
period
during which they were taking in a lot
of sugar and synthetic crap and um no
you don't need to anymore
um
and uh and you know becoming less active
and you know their their physiology
changed with their diet and activity
level through their childhood and
Adolescence and upon becoming adults
metabolic disease May well be the right
term here and I didn't actually look up
disease what other people think disease
means but
um this strikes me as you know the
complex serious and complex chronic
disease of obesity
that I feel like part of what that is
doing
is once again encouraging people
to take the control away from themselves
well I can't do anything
I couldn't make sure I get out in the
Sun every day and get and synthesize my
vitamin D and move my body around and
make Choi learn learn by making repeated
choices about what I eat to love food
that is also good for me
well I can't I can't do anything it's
easier if you just give me a pill
it's much easier and if I hear that it's
a disease that I've got
then that changes the conversation
something I can do it's a disease as
opposed to
you know what you're a kid and you are
not this is not your fault but you can
still take responsibility and your
parents should definitely take
responsibility and they should keep you
away from the doctors who were looking
at these guidelines as much as possible
so
at some level it's just a charade
right
you've got an industry
selling food that has a preserve
perverse incentive you've got an
industry selling pills which has got a
perverse incentive you've got an
industry selling surgery
it's got a perverse incentive and
there's no industry uh of leave kids
alone in a healthy environment that
doesn't make them sick right that they
don't have lobbyists there's nobody on
that side and so the thing that is
increasingly infuriating to me
is the pretense that this is about
science and medicine and study and
consternation about illnesses that
children are suffering it's not right
this is somehow about business and the
problem is the people doing it don't
even know that right I'm sure even in
Pharma they go to work and they think
well there's a
biological problem called obesity in
children and by gum we gotta address it
with some some molecules right
um and there is nobody I mean like
you know there used to be medicine
right it used to be doctors who had a
scientific bent who solved problems who
puzzled through what was making their
patients sick figured out what things
might work for them and there were
things like a second opinion right maybe
I don't want a medical establishment in
which every doctor agrees to what the
CDC said maybe I want two doctors to
disagree and I want to listen no but it
streamlines the process because there's
no need for a second opinion because you
know the second third fourth and nth
opinion will all be the same therefore
you don't need them right no so it does
streamline the process hey Doc these
check boxes what do I take right it's
that there's also
essentially no advocacy I can't remember
the last time I heard anybody say that
an ounce of prevention was worth a pound
of cure because you know an
ounce of prevention is a breach of the
fiduciary responsibility to shareholders
right prevention how are you going to
monetize prevention treatment that's
where the shareholders get their their
value pharmaceutical companies not for
doctors
well even doctors running a practice who
encourage
whatever they're called like the regular
healthy checkups or whatever like you
know or annual exams even but also just
oh you know what uh you know you're
pre-diabetic you're pre like this like
it would be great too
just have a sit down have a face to face
you patient me doctor every six months
like you know that that doesn't sound
like a breach of fiduciary
responsibility whether or not the doctor
is working for a hospital or their own
practice or whatever like if you're
encouraging you know encouraging
patients to come in for office visits
and actually develop a relationship with
them you know are they going to be
sicker sooner and therefore require more
drugs no but that's a good thing right I
agree with you there's no doctor
Corporation and I'm sure what I don't
know about how hmos and all of that work
you know is uh is a place where a lot of
stuff can be hidden but
um but at the very least the doctors are
captured by something that has fiduciary
responsibilities that we don't
understand all over the place and
uh
I mean
this pandemic diagnosed the system and
the diagnosis was you know it's got a
terminal illness
right and that terminal illness will
cause it to reverse the labels on cure
and poison right and once you have a
medical establishment that's willing to
do that whether it's because of threats
or perverse incentives or confusion
right the point is well okay that's not
medicine in the sense that we used to
think of it it's something else right
uh Pharma isn't in the business of
making people healthier right it's not
surprising that Pharma figured out that
that's not where it's but its bread is
buttered
so you know
what are we gonna do because
you know it's a great and tragic example
that you've you've brought to us here
where we're going to pretend that an
epidemic of obesity is not about
external inputs to the system having
changed in a way that has overwhelmed
restraint in children or overwhelmed
metabolism or whatever it did it
predominantly emerges from biological
factors
said the co-director of the Center for
Pediatric obesity medicine the
University of Minnesota which is both
true at a trivial level and so far
misses the mark in terms of what a
doctor in a position like this
needs to be thinking about and must know
must know
no right and you do find in the
guidelines you know mention of like
nutrition healthy lifestyle but you know
the big thing that made the headlines
that's new here
is
recommendations specifically identifying
the youngest age at which
you should start on drugs for 12 year
olds who are obese
if everything else has failed
and surgery for 13 year olds who are
obvious
if everything else is fail then I'm not
even sure that if everything else is
failed language is in there I want to
give them the benefit of the doubt but
I'm not even sure right that's how
they've framed it okay but we got to
separate these two things right because
it comes up in every one of these cases
they're the people who have already been
affected who may indeed have a permanent
problem a developmental impact on their
metabolism that causes them to have a
lifelong issue that we have to deal with
somehow right and then they're the
people who haven't been hurt yet and
indefinitely large group right all those
who have yet to be born who when they
are born will either be exposed to the
factor that made these other kids fat or
they won't right and so
we haven't heard them yet the amount of
good you even if you were stuck with a
bad situation for kids that have already
been affected and there's nothing you
can do for them that really works
the amount of good you can do by not
doing it to anybody else is
is indefinitely large and so why aren't
we focused there and why I mean even
that statement that you read
can you describe a scenario I'm not
asking for something that is really true
can you describe a scenario in which an
obesity epidemic in children is not
primarily happening with biological
factors I mean
it's a fact
[Laughter]
a fellow in it right
yeah those are nice it does feel like a
Hall of Mirrors it feels like a hall of
mirror maybe it's all halls and mirrors
maybe there are no obese kids and it's
just an illusion but short of that
you know what obesity is made of lipids
right you know how lipids get into the
body metabolism you know how metabolism
happens you eat stuff you know you eat
it with you masticate it with your teeth
and all it's all about you all the way
down right what else would it be right
the person has has like put on a lab
coat and said a tautology and
everybody's like oh yeah that's wise
well but I mean it also I mean this I
mean we could there's a whole
dissertation to be added unpacking this
really ridiculous statement that seems
so simple and was said with such
Assurance obesity is not a lifestyle
problem it is not a lifestyle disease it
predominantly emerges from biological
factors
first two sentences in that three
sentence statement
are not true for children
and um you know once once you're stuck
in it it likely is but the third
sentence if predominantly emergence of
biological factors is a non-sequitur
which is placed at the end of these
other two sentences as if it is a
rejoinder no it's not a rejoinder it's a
non-sequitur they're different they have
no relationship to one another obesity
does stem from the crazy hyper novel
lifestyle that we have pushed actively
on everyone for the last n years I don't
even know what to call it right but you
know you know starting sort of
starting but you know ramping up after
World War II how about yeah and it
predominantly emerges biological
factories oh that
density yeah it sounds okay well then
well let's do science that oh a pill
which factors which factors uh well for
example uh the big gulp uh that's one
another big things like the Mac the Big
Mac yeah
alphabetically a lot of the factors are
under uh under B
[Laughter]
okay
yeah slight change of topic no less
maddening but let's well all right okay
this is good I'm already pre-mad oh you
are you're pre-maddened yes
okay
um
you have presumably heard although you
hadn't heard about that one that the USC
School of Education and Michigan's
Department of Health and Human Services
both came out publicly against the use
of the word field
wait wait wait wait okay
um here we go
um
okay
wait are we talking about sports or are
we talking about disciplines
disciplines and offices yeah
yeah you can show my screen this is the
use I said field yesterday and you told
me this was going to come up yeah that
was not okay anymore this is the USS not
properly honor uh people who live in
forests and on coastlines field
the um
I don't even know who she is the someone
oh no this is the name of the school
sorry the School of Social Work at USC
has sent to everyone associate the
community The Faculty staff and students
as we enter 2023 we'd like to share a
change we are making it this is and work
pack for Jack I don't know
how you would spell torchak it doesn't
matter
um School of Social Work to ensure our
use of inclusive language and practice
specifically we have decided to remove
the term field from our curriculum and
practice and replace it with practicum
this change supports anti-racist Social
Work practice by replacing language that
could be considered anti-black or
anti-immigrant in favor of inclusive
language language can be powerful
and phrases such as going into the field
or field work may have connotations for
descendants of slavery and immigrant
workers that are not benign
give me my screen back sorry man
um and uh
the Michigan Michigan Department of
Health and Human Services so that was
private university this is now the state
of Michigan you don't show my screen I
just got a quote here
as an agency we will be discontinuing
use of terms like field work and field
workers instead staff can use terms like
Community office
local office and Community local office
staff
also yes this week I propose to you that
we'd not call gibberish that is actually
directed and not indicative of a
schizophrenic break word solid but word
soup that's word soup yeah that's some
hearty word soup yeah
um
here's the question
I understand
that that as a weapon
that you could use against somebody
speaking the English right like if you
were to just try to say something then
the chances that you will literally have
missed a memo that tells you why you're
not supposed to have used that term for
this thing
right chances are near certain so
presumably yeah and I've seen no
no explanation Beyond a little bit more
than what I've shared with you here
presumably this is about the historical
use of the word field to distinguish
between house and field
slaves
wait wait and you know and slave isn't
the word that was used right
but if that is the case which I which is
the best I can do like is the best I can
figure in terms of like how this word
comes to be in the
line the firing squad here
certainly house
is equally bad right equally dangerous
uh hurtful hurtful hurtful you might
have missed that memo
um yeah apparently but I mean really
is
as you speak
you can be certain that you are in
violation of a memo
somewhere somehow which will not be a
problem unless something decides that
you are inconvenient in which case it
will become a problem it's a low posted
speed limit it is a low poster woke
version right and and all of their
little traps are this way but what
what is impossible to imagine
first of all this isn't how language
works it just isn't how language works
right by Fiat we won't be using the word
field anymore
right or the word Fiat you have a
problem with that
or the word Fiat yes because it's a
also a car like well I don't know what I
don't know
um I don't know Italian
trauma something right
um but so I mean we
also like we've been field workers like
we we are field we're field biologists
we're not
um Community office biologists right
like we're field biologists as
distinguished from Lab biologist not as
distinguished from house biologists
because that's not what you do in
biology it's field versus lab and that
doesn't have a history of racism and no
I don't
you can't say lab you know why
why
um because of Labrador which is stolen
under the island Island The Province yes
yes well it's stolen land
I I believe the kids call this
problematizing things you turn them into
problems you can we can turn anything
into a problem and the point is we can
go all day this is really about the
power to put out the memos that then
allow you to dictate who is no longer
allowed to talk but what is
inconceivable is that anybody could be
keeping track of all of the things that
you are not supposed to say I mean maybe
if that was your full-time job
you could keep track of the things
you're not allowed to say well the
problem in part is that it's many
people's full-time jobs to come up with
the damn memos right clearly it's an
arms race you've got you got Dei offices
everywhere now and they're sitting
around twiddling their thumbs because
they were hired on false pretenses and
you know at Stanford which we talked
about a few weeks ago and at USC and at
Michigan Health and Human Services
they're like oh I know I'll be I'll be
proactive and come up with a job I'm
gonna
I'm gonna Outlaw a word that's what I'm
gonna do my work here is done yes until
tomorrow which point I'll figure out the
other words that I need to outlaw right
and the offices don't they're not in
good communication so it turns out that
silence is violence and speeches
violence which doesn't leave you a lot
of room it's again useful because you
can go after anyone anybody at any time
for anything they might be doing or not
doing yeah don't say that and how dare
you not how dare you yeah your silence
is deafening right um it's that world
but
can you imagine for a second
a prototypical person who is trying to
be good and not offend anybody by not
using words like field or house or
whatever the next problematized word is
going to be right okay so you are
filtering everything you say so that you
don't trip over any of these words by
speaking in the way people normally
speak where they don't parse everything
in advance right now
imagine that that person
has another job
are they able to do that other job while
they are so busy looking at every
utterance to see whether or not there
has been a memo that says that they're
not allowed to say that thing
my sense is if you did this if you took
that seriously that's all you are is
yeah I'm not gonna do that thing
so yeah that becomes your full-time job
that because yeah and you probably
probably won't be able to do it even
then right especially if the memos keep
coming out
um you know and uh no it's it's like um
uh we recently talked about in oh I
can't say I can't remember uh the World
War II book
um
long okay
[Laughter]
oh I should know yeah I know I'm just
drawing a complete blank um it doesn't
matter all right well uh
suffice it to say this needs to be
studied and that's going to require a
field
yeah I mean there was a lot more I
wanted to say here but let's let's move
on I just
I
when we talked about the Stanford words
yep
you could kind of imagine what they
thought they were up to
in each of the cases and it was
everywhere from silly to egregious
but
you you know one of my favorite ones was
like you shouldn't use the word seminal
because you know it's
because people think of cement I don't
like but like it it you know it it
unfairly genderizes stuff whatever
um
at least there's a like a there and
there like that's stupid don't stop it
but you know at least you can sort of
track back like oh I guess I see what
they're doing right
like
if they literally never run into anyone
who works in the field who does field
work who like
I
I just failed to grasp how they could
have ever left
like the bedroom that they grew up from
and spent their entire childhood on
social media presumably like it feels it
feels so narrow and so
I'm so atrocious a life to be to be
putting up memos like this right it is
it's it's an empty empty existence but
it catch 22. that's the number that's
the one yes yes it's some catch well no
it was it's the the
when the guy keeps coming out the memos
and the memos and the memos oh the uh
the great loyalty oath campaign yeah
yeah exactly it's it's that thing all
over it it's that thing but look
this once again of course is sophistry
and imagine for a second that the game
was
that it was an analog of the social
media game right where the idea is can I
put something out on a social media
platform that gets engagement or anger
or reposted or whatever right and the
extent that you can't you are shouting
and to avoid it's no fun it's
frustrating and to the extent that you
put something into the world that makes
a ripple you get a little something
right so now imagine
that you have a serious bureaucracy
that is its purpose is to protect
Stanford so that Stanford will continue
to stand indefinitely right and the
point is you can use your own
demographic markers to introduce
anything you want into the conversation
to see if you can make them jump right
and it's like uh
you know that word field
it's not a good word you know there are
a lot of us out here every time we hear
that we are traumatized do you know why
uh well of course we do but we'd like to
hear you elaborate on this uh yeah field
right explain the problem of field well
do you know where slaves worked uh oh
got it field memo right and so how cool
a game is that that you can get the I
mean in a world in which you are
otherwise unempowered right disempowered
because uh the world is crazy and maybe
also because you have no skills uh you
know what a power Rush what a rush to be
able to affect
change
okay but but
let's just
some of these people are just monsters
but some of these people most of them
aren't but you can imagine I mean look
okay let's take all things pandemic okay
whatever else is true whoever you happen
to be you were just served so poorly by
the civilization that you know taxes you
and regulates you and all of this you
were just you you were the the level at
which you were protected was beyond
abysmal right
and you have no power to affect change
there's nobody to vote for right it's
just like endless monotony and trying
not to you know go to jail and the point
is
well
I guess my point is I can imagine look
the distaste
that the dysfunction of our civilization
would naturally produce in anybody who
was paying attention
is liable to have an outgrowth and if
the outgrowth is all right
I mean you know the class clown right
the class clown has figured out
something that's at least interesting
right the class clown has figured out
that maybe there's nothing for him in
that room
unless he can turn that room into a
comedy opportunity and then that's it
that's amusing you can get a room full
of people to laugh and then you can
watch the teacher pull their hair out
and you know so it's that kind of thing
and I ca it is it is that kind of play
yep yeah and so I look I hate the
monsters who don't care about the harm
that they do to innocent people but I
understand the person who is bored and
annoyed that they have been given no
good path to anything useful and
expected just to suck it up right I
understand that person looking for
opportunities to you know for high
things and to the extent that might be
hijinks I don't know well and that's I
mean to take it back a little bit that's
part of why I guess mostly in the summer
of 2020 we were coming down so hard on
the ibrahamex candies and uh whatever
her name is white fragility lady
um uh Crenshaw D'Angelo oh no
D'Angelo yeah
um
uh you know uh candy who wrote the
anti-racist or how to be an anti-racist
or anti-racist baby right
um and but both both of them from their
different perches as you know a black
man and a white woman uh were you know
proclaiming racism everywhere and uh the
need for effectively reparations in
every single moment of every single day
for every single human being who can't
claim to have been oppressed in this one
very particular demographic way yeah
right and it just it opens up this
apparent Avenue
for people who never would have seen it
as an Avenue and wouldn't have been
encouraged to take it but for the fact
that suddenly and especially in an era
when there's so little opportunity and
so much is falling apart it's like well
okay I you know I'm smart enough I can
get stuff done and I've got this one
little demographic marker of some sort
and you know it doesn't be any number of
things and guess who is hiring all the
Dei offices because everyone's got Dei
offices now yeah it's an affirmative
action program a cryptic one well but I
don't no I'm actually I'm not no that's
that's not what I'm saying at all it's
it's you funnel you you encourage people
and this is part of what I've been
saying about part of what the you know
the the trans rights activists are about
you know as opposed to like the you know
very very rare true trans people but you
know trans is on the rise in part
because it's the one of these
demographic markers that you can opt
into and just one day you're like yep
that's me and now all you know all those
same Dei offices that are you know the
only the only people they're not open to
are you know straight white dudes who
were born dudes and they're still dudes
right and you know that's you know less
than a majority and and you have I would
say it's not affirmative action it's a
job yeah it's a it's a make work jobs
program right there's no real work to be
done
understand that a colorblind Society is
desirable and that we're not quite there
and but you know it's not like you need
people to studiously figure out what to
do about all the you know interactions
and words that people might say without
permission and all of that but the
problem is the problem is
it's exactly analogous to the
post-modernists right that by providing
a foot in the door for post-modernism
the post-modernists were incubated and
became post-modern activists that took
over the universities and by creating a
Dei program the point is oh well they
sure are going to find some stuff to
complain about because that's what
effectively what you've appointed them
to do well and once it exists
uh everyone will work to try to ensure
that their job stays relevant enough for
them to keep a job yeah and so you know
and this is something we've been talking
about since since Evergreen blew up
right like you don't um
um it's very hard to convince people
whose profession professional position
is
things have always sucked things
continue to suck and things will not
stop sucking that oh actually things are
getting better and therefore we need
less of the constant talk about sucking
now because what am I supposed to do
then that's what I do that's why I
taught that's what I do is I talk about
how awful everything is so I am actually
um not maybe even able anymore to see
that things in some Realms are getting
better because that would put me out of
a job
right right well can we talk about fish
we've been talking about fish for the
whole time puffer fish oh good yeah
uh okay uh Zach is going to show this
video and um sound off although I think
there's um
subtitles but you don't need just just
watch and I'm gonna we're gonna talk
over it
so this is a
I'm gonna talk even though there's words
on the screen so you're gonna hear it or
me
um and you can choose
so in 2014 this puffer fish was named uh
and
uh it was 1995. uh this is these are
these are found off of the uh I think
it's pronounced ryukyu Islands in Japan
between
um just north of Taiwan
and uh the uriki islands and certainly
which has a lot of really interesting
stuff in it and I'd like to go at some
point I'm just yeah it's just a just a
point where you're here is there a
geological reason they are uh
interesting I don't know
um um biologic I I it looks it looks
like a rift edge of some sort but I know
very little about it except when I went
to find figure out where these puffer
fish were and I found once again yet
another fascinating you know animal
behavior story that I was interested in
it's like oh it's in the ryuku it's like
again okay what's going on there I don't
know anyway uh in I think I said the 99
1995 scuba divers had been noticing
these underwater circles
um and didn't know to what to attribute
them and it was a long time it was um a
couple almost a couple of decades
uh before uh in 2013
a paper in scientific reports came out
called roll of huge geometric circular
structures in the reproduction of a
marine puffer fish
and so here it is zooming out now you
can see like this this animal has just
made this incredible thing it takes him
I think the BBC said two two weeks oh
but yeah the the scientific paper says
seven to nine days working just
constantly because of course this isn't
you know not Tides change what he's
building here so it's a he it's a he
it's a he and uh the behavioral
description of what's going on actually
came before the scientific name of the
fish so that that's just an interesting
little little glitch right in the usual
order of things where we didn't even
know for sure that this wasn't a species
that had already been named and was just
doing something different then it's you
know it's kin elsewhere uh until after
the behavior was described and is that
replaying yeah so when we can we can
stop now
um
so males are spending seven to nine days
it's always males they have a big
question for you yeah
do we know it's mating system
I don't see any evidence of it but well
no I I I I can tell you what little I
know and we can predict it well yes uh
so Mel spends seven to nine days
actively making and tending these nests
and there are at least three
characteristics of these nests they're
here to for unknown otherwise in fishy
fish in Ray Fin fish acting up to
Regions uh and other I mean there's a
lot of fascinating fish behavior of
course as as we've talked about a little
bit but as many people will will know
but those readily aligned Peaks and
valleys outside of the actual Nest site
um no one's ever seen fish do that
before those placing of the shell
fragments along the Peaks is new in fish
behavior and then the fine sand
particles gathered in the nest site
which you couldn't necessarily see but
maybe you can infer having now seen the
big geometric design from on high that
they specifically are are moving the
sand around to create a central what
ends up being the nest a very fine sand
and those three things the Peaks and
valleys outside the shell fragments on
the Peaks and the fine sand in the
middle in its own geometric but slightly
more regular pattern are all constructed
and maintained before mating before a
female ever shows up sure female shows
up so wait wait I want to predict this
stuff before you okay I don't I don't
know very much but uh yeah go for it
um so
it's going to be a polygenous
mating system not clear
well I'm going to predict that it will
be it that males will invest nothing in
that if that's a male they will invest
nothing in Offspring Beyond gametes yeah
I think that's not true not true so
that's part of why I want to do this is
see whether the system is any different
because you know what it of course looks
like is a an aquatic bowerbird analog
are the circles near each other
I don't know
and I don't know if my read was uh
incomplete or if it wasn't described
um
they are
after the females visit the nests the
nests mostly collapse and then they get
so that the eggs are laid on fine sand
and they're covered with coarser sand
and it's is likely it seems to me
um that the finest of the sand increases
Fitness of the eggs
these are the locations where the eggs
are laid the middle of that area so
you've got the radial arms outside of
the center like imagine sort of like a
daisy the middle part ends up like a
daisy being the actual reproductive part
so that's very unlike the bowerbird
example yeah well
um
in in some ways in some ways
um but yeah I mean it is it's it's kind
of it is very much actually like a daisy
I hadn't occurred to me before so that
you know in terms of you know the petals
are basically the The Lure from afar uh
for you know not other daisies but you
know the vectors the pollinators
um to come and pollinate and it's the
center thing it's the center ring
um that is where the eggs are actually
laid so then it might not be a
belliginous system this might be a
mysteriously valuable structure and well
and it's it's mysteriously valuable it
starts collapsing in and of itself
quickly I think
um that there is there are a few days of
sort of male tendon attendance so male
parental care and then he goes and
builds another one
and uh it's it's off and starts over
from scratch once the once the first one
so it it may be actually a promiscuous
system in which
um you know if if you have built the
careful nest and you can attract a good
mate that's great and you have that one
thing and then after that whatever it is
a few weeks
you can go and and build another yeah so
this is actually potentially closer to
your frogs
um where a male might have multiple
Wells I see there's no description of
what I found of territoriality uh and
that's not to say that they're not I
would expect that they are I see no
description of therefore uh the quality
of the substrate right uh you know what
what determines where where the fish
choose to to build these nests and um
and aesthetic structures around them
well one thing that's likely to be true
is that structure is likely to be very
difficult to build and maintain if there
are currents and actually you can uh you
can just put it back on while we're
talking as long as we're talking about
these guys uh yes and I think they're in
slightly deep water but yes they're
occurrence and this is this is exactly
true I think I said this already that
the maintenance of the structure is
needs to be constant that basically as
soon as the maintenance stops so that's
it the thing decays which you would kind
of expect because if the male if neither
of the fish are going to defend the
thing then what you don't want to do is
call is signal potential egg Predators
right that this is a structure so you
would want it to kind of break down but
it's like these what are those like uh
giant like Buddhist sand art oh I was
thinking that too right you could take
I don't know like weeks months maybe
even to create and they're gorgeous and
intricate and then the point is in part
so they get wiped clean shortly after
they are completed
um in that case there is not a um a
reproductive motive so so what we're
looking at
this seems to be either some new kind of
system or one of two known kinds of
systems it looks like a bower bird kind
of scenario but that doesn't sound like
Barrow bird Behavior if the eggs are
being laid there yeah and it's unlike so
they're they're what something less than
20 I think species something around two
dozen-ish species of bear birds in
Northern Australia and and Papua New
Guinea and there's different there's
different things that different bear
birds do but they they build these
structures that
females the males build these stretches
the females are attracted to but they
have some permanence to them yeah and
they do you know they do Decay it's the
tropics and and they steal from each
other the male Barrel Birds steal from
one another and uh but they're in a spot
they're territorial of the spot and they
build a structure on the spot the bower
and that spot is a spot that any female
can come back to over and over again and
unless something has happened
um she knows that if she's in that spot
it's going to be that guy whereas uh
exiled Bowers they do but the these are
these do not appear to be
um
territorial yeah um yeah that's why
that's why I think the the bowerberg
connection is superficial I was wrong to
go there I mean it looks like it and the
shell part of the story you know I'd be
curious whether they steal shells from
each other something like that
um and whether there is a display well
so the thought I had about the shells
was
the the functional part of this is the
is the center of the daisy right it's
it's the nest that's where the eggs are
going to be
and my guess is that the eggs are
actually somewhat fragile and they need
a very soft very finely grained sand
nest and the sort of the Petals of the
daisy the pedal the the would-be Petals
of this of this structure that he's
building are the visual attractant from
onfar but the shells he's pulling from
inside the nest as an indicator of I've
cleaned the area it's it's clear it's
clear of the debris that would
negatively impact your eggs which is
reminiscent that is again reminiscent of
bower birds and maybe even more so birds
of paradise right the cleaning of the
Dance Floor uh is a I don't know if it's
Universal but it's close for for all of
those species
um and you know you make a lot of
arguments for why that might be but I
think mannequins too I think mannequins
clean their clean their
um little dance pads in those that have
flat pads as opposed to Sticks maybe not
I don't know I'm more familiar with the
stick dancing uh mannequins but
um but anyway interesting because you've
got features of multiple terrestrial
systems
um I'd be very curious to to know what's
actually going on here yeah
yeah so maybe we should get to the
ryukyu islands and uh right now no no I
died no one thing it's probably very
cold there right now yeah
yeah
um well
I think we've been at it quite a while
yes we have and uh maybe we should stop
for this week and come back in a week
that's not Prime
um yeah that's gonna happen soon yeah
and uh we will take a break and then
come back and do our q a so you can ask
questions at darkhorsesmissions.com
that's that is open now you can ask
questions there uh you we encourage you
again to go to our patreons if you want
to join the Discord Community or ask
questions for our monthly q a you can
find that at my patreon and
um
and yeah lots of other good stuff maybe
that's it for now
until we see you next time be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside you will everyone
[Music]
[Music]